ja ich bin böse sie uns nur was einmal
beschäftigen heute werden wir uns mit
die interpreten verfassen
das internet ist wie sie alle wissen ein
hoch komplexes phänomen
und es ist vielleicht neben der
künstlichen intelligenz das thema was
uns singen haben qualität vor allem
behandelt werden muss aber jetzt auf
dieses thema internet hier eingeben
möchte ich noch mal einen kurzen
rückblick blieben auf die letzte sitzung
und wählen sie sich bestimmte hatten wir
unsere der künstlich die liegames
befasst und wir hatten auch ein text
gelesen von niederhummel über diese
frage auch künstliche intelligenz
irgendwann an menschlichen zellen
und ich möchte dass die kurze
zusammenfassung noch mal geben haben sie
alle die in zusammenfassungen bekommen
per email oder die lowcost auf der apple
also wir haben verschiedene phänomene
uns überlegt wie man computer zu
schreiben könnte zwar können die normale
kurz klassifizieren und kategorisieren
erkennen lernen
stichwort die learning merken vernetzen
erinnern wissen verstehen denken
begreifen vorstellen entscheiden und zu
handeln
das sind alles unikate die man geneigt
ist künstlichen intelligenzen
zuzuschreiben
und wir wollen jetzt einfach mal schauen
ob das wirklich so ist das wirklich
angemessen auf künstliche gänze
übertragen werden kann auch die frage ob
man überhaupt wirklich von künstlicher
intelligenz sprechen ob man das
überhaupt at grad 100
dazu möchte ich nochmal verweisen auf
diesen neuen film haben sich die man
gehört das ist so kurz zimmern zur
akustischen kilo potter
marcel ich habe da eine sendung gemacht
zum thema weil können die wirklich
denken diese ganzen system und jetzt
möchte ich so ein bisschen marke eigene
gedanken auch hier einbringen und zwar
möchte ich an diesem phänomen der
mustererkennung ansätzen also wir haben
ja hier gesehen sie können können sich
neuronale netzwerke erstellt und die den
gelingt es am ende großen von schulden
zu unterscheiden oder auch
gesichtserkennung und so weiter das kann
alles muster erkennen muss eine
erkennung ist mit dasjenige was den
künstler hervorgebracht hat und jetzt
kann sich fragen bedeutet muss der
erkennung also wenn sie jetzt also
neuronales netz trainiert haben dass es
sehr gut gesichter erkennen also aus dem
ganz komplexen daten hat mir die
gesichter heraus kriegt kann man dann
sagen dass diese dem begriff verstehen
haben diese neuronalen letzten ein bmw
von gesicht
verstehen sie was ein gesicht ist es
muss man sich natürlich fragen was ist
denn ein begriff überhaupt gibt es
verschiedene ansichten zur idee was ist
was würden sie sagen das ist mir sagen
ich habe einen begriff von etwas ja
genaue konzept kategorie richtig andere
anwendungen
gewisse vorstellung oder assoziationen
vielleicht definition genau das ist
unser wasser der definition sagt auch
aristoteles gehört auch zu wickeln der
logos zu testen
jetzt kann man sich überlegen haben
diese norm oder im erzählen diese
künstlichen ein begriff last wenn sie
etwas richtig klassifizieren zu
garantieren heißt ein phänomen ist ein
einzelnes daten phänomen unter einer
kategorie zu bringen versteht dieses
system dann was ist mit der kategorie
aussicht also hat es den begriff dieser
kategorie und jetzt habe ich eine idee
gehabt könnte man nicht im begriff des
musters unter dass dieses phänomen
subsumiert wird mit der stimme nur teils
klar
damit muss das zu definieren dass damit
ein begriff geprägt
also kann man nicht muster als begriff
verstehen etwa im sinne alle möglichen
konstellationen die für
sein bruder abschattung abschattung
könnte man diesen begriff abschaltung
das ist eine trennung in logischer
begriff von edmund muss er meint damit
folgendes wenn wir einen gegenstand
betrachten können mit denen sie ganz
verschiedenen perspektiven betrachten
der gegenstand sieht aus wie nur ein
ich kann ihm den stuhl herum gelaufen
ich kann die rückseite betracht wenn das
mein abschaffen der gegenstand zeigt
sich mini von allen seiten um dieses
pilzes sehen und seiner ganzen gestalt
muss ich um es herum laufen zeigt mir
nur für eine seite
und jetzt kann man sagen ein gutes
trainiertes neuronales netz hat eine
abschaltung eines gegenstandes erfasst
zb gesichter oder köpfe die nicht nur
von vorne fotografiert sind schon mal
von der seite gesicht sieht von der
seite völlig anders aus erfahrung und
von schwerte hinten auch wenn sie jetzt
mal überlegen sondern an das netz was so
gut trainiert ist dass es gesichter aus
diesen daten mehr ausbilden kann auch
wenn die gesichter nur von der zeit
getroffen
könnte man sagen es hat auch die
abschaltung internet und jetzt könnt ihr
euch fragen ist es wäre ein so verzog
solches manöver namens netz welches alle
abschattung also noch so schräge winkeln
aus dem zb im gesicht fotografiert und
das erkennen kann
wäre das nicht in der lage im ende denn
dann tatsächlich einen begriff davon zu
besitzen wenn es alle möglichen
konstellationen solche objekte erfassen
kann
jetzt gehen schritt weiter könnte
künstlich entwickeln sich auch ein meta
musst entwickeln also musste die sich
wiederum auf muster beziehen und da
irgendwann das menschliche begriffs
vermögen zum beispiel besteigen methan
ist also dass man weiß in welcher
konstellation gewisse muster wiederum
vorlegen während meter ist halte ich für
nicht auszuschließen
und jetzt kommt der letzte punkt ich
glaube dass man über neue netze so
entstehen könnte dass sie in eine art
von populismus und paris muss heißt
immer die gesamte konstellation
betrachten damit will ich folgendes
sagen es gibt theorien ist verstehe aber
die bedeutung eines begriffs er misst
sich daran wie der begriff abgegrenzt
wird von anderen begriffen geben der
nicht sind also praktisch dass man sagt
tisches nicht entstehen ist nicht ein
pult ist nicht das es liegt dass es
nicht dass das ein
ein begriff semantisch stift durch die
abgrenzung durch die negation der
konstellation
jetzt könnte man sich überlegen ob nicht
ein aber dann gäbe es so zu einer
bedeutung gelangen könnte das ist alle
musste voneinander ab das alte das
muster darin besteht dass es das nicht
es das nicht ist das ganze
das ist nur so ein impuls nicht mal
geben möchte ich glaube dass durch diese
mussten hier wirklich um große von dem
zeigen leben müssen dass wir das nicht
vorschnell abtun sollten also wenn
irgendwann der grenze intelligenz
potenzial steckt dann sicherlich in der
münster kann was werden da der
unterschied zum schnellen werden
schweden wert wäre eben nur dazu da dass
erst ab einer bestimmten
informationsdichte überhaupt einen
prozess in gang gesetzt der
schwellenwert ist ja diese nachbildung
unserer zum absender achse funktioniert
erst dann gehen hier
dieses system und haben mit xp home
singen und er ist auch mit bestimmten
würde zum beispiel jeweils angesetzt
hier ist ab hier einstellen werde erst
einmal ganz nächste schwere merkt man
einfach nur dass man daten rauschen und
um informationen von außen vor lässt der
ist so richtig ins nach wichtig dass in
die gewichtung inzwischen redet
einzusetzen das war auch ein
ausschlussverfahren die zusagen dass so
alle musiker werden derart gut dass man
könnte diese muster erkennung über dem
schwellenwert reden dass man die
funktion lieber ist aber zu aufwendig
man ändert immer nur die gewichtungen
also wie wichtig eine verbindung eines
neuen ein feines netz ist
mit diesen aktionen konzert ist nicht zu
nah ja genau ich mache jetzt auch von
künstlichen ohren an grenzen hatte sie
meint es biologisch oder krause ich
glaube wie dank dir also sie sehen die
die 900 künstliche neuronale netze sind
modelle oder nachbildung von diesen
glücklichen und da gibt es keine
unterschiede aber das sind die bemerkung
des nächtlichen zu fördern
dann könnte auch die funktionierende
stellenwert geben und dann schauen man
immer unterstellen der funktion bessere
ergebnisse herausgekommen aber man macht
das übergewichtung weil das dann einfach
ein mathematisch zu berechnen ist durch
matrizen multiplikation aber viele
faktoren die man dann mit seinem sind
also ich wollte jetzt nur darauf
hinweisen musste erkennung schalten wir
ganz nach dem begriff vermögen zu geben
und zwar dann wenn ein muster sehr
reflektiert gewonnen wurde wenn es sich
aus abgrenzung von anderen möglichen
muster ergibt dann könnte man sagen hat
man sein wissen das und es muss man
immer das gar nichts ganzes und dann
könnte man sagen hatten und so ein
konstrukt uhr hätte der unter umständen
auch unsere semantische entspricht das
wissen wir gewinnen begriffen und
dadurch dass er sie unterscheiden
verhandeln das ist nicht dass das nicht
dass das nicht dieses verfahren scheint
mir ganz gerichtet sein bei dem muster
kennen es möchte aber noch ganz kurz auf
dieses buch für mich an ideen eingehen
was wir in der letzten sitzung kurz nur
der handel konnte mein herr nida rümelin
in seinem werk digitale humanismus sehr
kritisch ist was künstliche intelligenz
angenommen ich möchte ihnen noch ein
paar punkte abnehmen und wir wollen
die menschliche vernunft sagt mir die
menschliche fähigkeit überzeugung
entscheiden und motive einstellungen zu
begründen und auf dieser grundlage ein
kohärentes welt wird und eine quentin
praxis entwickeln lässt sich nicht im
modell eines digitalen kompass erfasst
es hat nie gelegen die hohe komplexität
unserer lebenswerten begründung
vollständig in adäquater weise formal zu
erfassen computer und software systeme
funktionieren an einem algorithmus
menschen nicht da haben blink einer
lehrerin zentrale unterstützung bekommen
ja wie sehen sie das
also würden sie die zustimmung eines
werden ich hatte also das ganze bitte
diese sachen komplexität spricht sagt
wenn unsere geistigen auch falls spricht
viel für die seitliche beschaffen genug
komplexer werden dass wir dahin kommen
diese komplexität dabei
dass wir ein komplettes leben haben von
dem wir nicht wissen ob es zukünftig mal
angenommen
genau kann ohne recht genau als völlig
richtig komplexität scharnier so ein
quantitatives phänomens zahl kann auch
qualitativ natürlich sein aber wenn es
nur um komplexität geht dann ist es mit
frage der zeit bis wir einfach neue
komplexitäten erlangen könnte man nicht
sagen
ein menschliches wesen eine person ein
freies wesen ist eben durch eine ganz
besondere komplexität ausgezeichnet
sagte auch und jetzt muss man eben
versuchen diese komplexität zu erlangen
gibt es also ein quantitative würde oder
eine qualität das ist die frage
die individuellen erfahrungen die die
einzelnen person wie kann das das
alltags einzigartiges wer bestimmt über
eine erfahrung die man hat lang
unterscheiden von den von der
künstlichen intelligenz wo er chef de in
bezug darauf den anderen agiert diesen
individuellen genau kann man überhaupt
von erfahrung sprechen oder auch von so
was wie empfindung das natürlich noch an
das thema diese empfindung kultur
stellen habe neuronale netz in
künstliche haben die so was wir vor
stimmen ich würde sagen begriff kann man
so fassen dass es abgrenzung oder die
definition ist aber hat dann ein system
eine vorstellung
auch zu gehen hier haben wir dieses
bewusstsein ist
und es kommt natürlich noch nicht mehr
auf den maschinen ja als bewusstsein ist
sehr wichtiger punkt und zwar wie wir
sagte wüssten selbst halt in zwei formen
bewusstsein werbung zum beispiel so was
wie emotionen zu erleben das wäre also
phänomenales bewusst sein soll ist
glaube ich auch dass man nicht in
anderen menschen die in rheine kommen
kann wenn man sich mal ein system und
ich kann jetzt neben der person wird
immer in den gleichen bereits laufen
sollte wir würden das vielleicht noch
anders erklären was wir jetzt gerade
gefühlt haben und die kommunikation ist
da auch nicht eindeutig auch bei
schmerzen kann ich sagen oder wie sich
das genauer an dann kann ich nicht
normal aus und bewegung ist da glaube
ich die definition der stier gegebener
zusagen
ab wann ist er jetzt uns in welcher der
uns gegenseitig wahrscheinlich machen
können was passiert deshalb direkt
sondern genau das was die meinten dass
man es schmeckt schlecht begreifen kann
das ist zb phänomenales bewusstsein war
hier in der scania das beweist gerade
hier zum beispiel schmerz schmerz nie
zustande
und dann kam es gar nicht begriff nicht
fassen ich kann nichts sagen so ist es
grün zu sehen
grün sehen definieren geht nicht ganz
was sagen das ist es nicht mit dieser
welt läge und so weiter wenn es irgendwo
trifft aber das erklärt wenn ich das im
qualitativen grünheid und das ist ein
problem bei consumer mehrere meldung ist
hier aber eigentlich braucht man das
auch gar nicht erklären man wilde farm
ekd ist die menschen endlich gemeldeten
menschen von außen betrachtet als sich
ihnen folgendes informationen und
zweiter unter handelt
schnitte art dann brauche ich die bayern
gar nicht klickt ein traum im kurs - da
hat man irgendwie habe und was genau
jetzt braucht man dabei reichlich gar
nicht als die frage ist ob man eben
solche neuronalen netzen verhalten zu
sprechen kann das ist eine spannende
frage
man könnte eben auch sagen das ist nur
eine operation so war es also ein
algorithmus erlaubt einfach halle
verhalten wäre immer so ein bisschen was
auf einen zweck hingerichtet zu sein der
aus einem selbst kommt und wir hatten ja
gesagt werden zweck kommt von solche
neuronalen system für solche künstlichen
jetzt immer verkaufen und dazu sagen zu
sagen sagt könnte es ein verhaltenes
spiel müsste der innere antrieb kommen
ja wobei damals unklar das auch
gerechtigkeit in die welt kommt
revolutionär überlebenstrieb und also
dass daraus vor
von außen gekommen ja man könnte
natürlich sagen der mensch ist auch nur
ganz ganz komplexe algorithmus und zwar
so komplexe algorithmus dass der
algorithmus einzigartig ist dass man
sagen jedes individuum jeder frei mensch
kein mensch wird definiert durch einen
singulären algorithmus als algorithmus
der unverwechselbar
typisch für dieses frei wesen ist dann
könnte man freiheit als singulären oder
individuellen algorithmus es gibt solche
möglichkeiten zum beispiel leibnitz
argumentiert ins gericht bleibt netz
diese besagt dass freiheit ein
individuelles gesetzt kann keine form
von unterhaltung höheres gesetz welt
sondern wird die freie person sich
selbst zum gesetze durch ihre
unverwechselbare individualität und so
könnte man sagen
während freie person vielleicht systeme
die nach einem individuellen algorithmus
funktionierte überaus komplexen wobei
hier der alten st
richtig wichtig aber richtig wichtig
sondern als er müsste dann praktisch ein
künstliches neuronales netz entwickeln
was irgendwie eine individualität
besitzt nun versuchen über die
individualität daran zu kommen dass wenn
die möglichkeit habe ich bin immer ein
bisschen skeptisch wenn man von
verhalten spricht weil das und
animistische konzept ist was wirklich
zum zweck vorauszusetzen
da braucht man hier gar nicht braucht
man sicherlich nicht aber eben um
bewusstsein und höhere fähigkeiten zu
sprechen zu können an dem system muss
man im quali empfänger kann
traditionsbewusstsein dieser ganzen zeit
wenn keine qual da sind kann man nicht
bewusst sein zustand sei die frage will
man sein system überhaupt sollten system
überhaupt bewusst sein so zu entwickeln
dass die frage wenn man es geben annimmt
und dann kann die messestadt von redet
müsstest du was man auch möglichst
darunter vergleichbaren mitwirken beim
menschen glauben dann von innen ich
ertrage
da schauen wir mal ob man nicht auch gar
nicht zu fragen
ist richtig der eltern sind das müssen
wir eine software sprache können nicht
mit unseren menschlichen sprache aber
das ist nicht so einfach ein bisschen so
eine blackbox das ist richtig und aber
was was sie zu recht gesagt haben ist es
müsste so eine kommunikation stattfinden
es ist eine kommunikation stattfinden
und zwar müsste von diesem system von
selbst aus autonom nicht von außen folgt
dem fall selbst eine tendenz enthalten
sein die die kommunikation sucht das als
sie von dem systems selbst etwas kommt
was ich nicht davor schon eingepreist
haben und das ist die spannende frage
sein zustandekommen was bestimmt uns die
menschen verstehen ja auch kein gewinn
es ist das schon werden die menschen von
außen irgendwie auch zu begreifen wenn
man einem lebewesen oder ein wesen oder
emeka ministerin
anders als man es gibt gewisse zeichen
signale ein zeichensystem wir können da
schließen wie es tieren geht
wir wissen nicht genau wie es uns geht
tiere wissen teilweise auch wie es uns
geht wenn es gibt nur eine gewisse form
von kommunikation
aber halt sein
er ist von person zu person ganz sind
noch so wollte auch in weiteren sprachen
an wird und weil das ist eigentlich dass
ich habe 60
diesen personen ich glaube ihnen da dass
mehr menschen zum beispiel gerade mit
einem internets zb größe system schotten
gemeinsam bearbeitet werden
sie sind wie das zum beispiel eines
kommunikativen wäre es auch unter
menschen wird dass wir im system
beschreiben können was sie bauen können
die physikalischen ebene funktioniert
ich hoffe niemand weiter gegen diesen
versuch zu erklären und in dieser
instanz wegen seiner eigenen formationen
zu schließen das heißt eigentlich
sprachen sowie schlimmer etwas getrennt
von dieser jugendspiele untersten senken
und das zwei gerade bei uns ganz wichtig
weil es grundsätzlich 50 intelligenz bau
und architektur nach der nächsten wochen
das brauchtum august stattfinden kann
die komische momente und diesen müsst
ihr erst durch
dauert das feld zu werfen muss sich
entwickeln kann
das musikalischste unterschiedlichen
sich unsere wesentlichen den fans
empfehlen können
das heißt es für mich diese fremde und
unsere persönlich
[Musik]
also ein guter hinweis wir haben hier
grundsätzlich differenzen auch was
unsere materielle basis anbelangt man
kann sich fragen ist es möglich
selbstbewusstsein künstliche intelligenz
nicht nur auf kohlenstoffbasis wie es
bei uns der fall ist zu entwickeln dann
vielleicht auf siliziumbasis oder auch
eine ganz ganz anders ist das dir meine
these ist die dass erst dann wirklich
fertig entsprechen können ich habe es
auch in einer sitzung gesagt in einem
podcast
wenn wir lebendige wesen haben eine
bande gewesen heißt wenn wir wesen haben
aus innerem antrieb zwecke verfolgen
erst dann glaube ich können wir diese
prädikate adäquat zu schreiben und so
lange wir nicht dieses lebendige systeme
haben diese selbst geschlossene system
können wir nur hypothetisch als immer
nur relativ von solchen kognitiven
fähigkeiten entsprechen das netzwerk
erkennt etwas aber nur nachdem ich ihm
etwas vorgesetzt haben und ihm den
begriff gebracht haben dann ist oft zu
mir das drunter jetzt gar nicht fragen
kann ein solches system neue mittel
verschaffen kann es von sich aus zum
neuen ergebnissen komme ich würde nicht
ausschließen ich habe dass das metall
monster genannt
dass man also irgendwann kommt wir haben
ja bestimmte muster erkannt und auf
basis dieser mustererkennung schließen
wir auf eine höhere erstelltes musste
dass diese verschiedene muster sind so
an geworden ich gebe ein beispiel wir
haben hier mustern
hier musste und hier musste und jetzt
schließen daraus dass das tier sich
dabei um
die geometrische formen lassen und dann
komme ich immer höre diese frage kann
ich aufsteigen ließen diese bewegung von
unten nach oben oder unten hat meldete
auf ein roboter motto und so in diese
bewegung dass wenn die spannende sache
wenn man als hörer stufige musste kennt
weil das leder was die typische art war
nicht bewusst oder von reflexivität wir
sehen ein muster das verbindung und eine
geordnetes musste und das so weiter
sofort da kommen wir auch zum
etablierten und da könnte man sagen sie
ganz von dem der vorgang selbst
persönlichkeit entwickelt habe ich
jemanden auf platz eins an den banken
die heute vielleicht noch einen gedanken
aufgreifen
da könnte man die grenze doch ziehen
oder die betrifft der kreatur eingeführt
zu dieser arbeit schweizern hat sich ja
mit dem was sie auf lange zeit
das war für mich ein vernünftiger
grenzziehung kreatur meinen sie mit
kreaturen lebewesen und eine schön mein
kreatur ist ja eigentlich geschrieben
und könnte man nicht sagen auch
künstliche neuronale netze sind auf
unsere geschäft
sie sind noch mehr schaffen die natur
hat sie vielleicht nicht direkt
erschaffen aber vielleicht mittelbar
über uns als natur hat uns erschaffen
und wir haben die netze schaffen wäre es
ja auch ne kreaturen unsere kreatur oder
mittelbar die der tante oder der distanz
auch immer ich glaube ich glaube dass
der schlüssel
ich glaube dass da was dran ist in der
kreaturen ich glaube dass man über der
mitte des lebens gehen muss muss sein
ohne abhängige system sein was auch noch
existiert wenn ich ihm keine daten der
einspeise keine daten mehr einspeisen
sondern es müsste sich selbst diese
daten holen so wie wir zum beispiel
nahrung aufnehmen also kurz gesagt man
könnte in analogie dingen ein
künstliches netz müsste stoffwechsel
systeme betreiben und stoffwechsel
während informations wechseln es müsste
immer weiter neue daten nimmt sich
selbst suchen auf neue felder sind an
den ideen von bolivien brauchen oder
photosynthese und aus diesen neuen daten
neue muster erkennen würde dass sich
selbst verbessern durch neue lerneffekte
hier ist nur bekommen wenn historische
erbe und so wurde es dann sich praktisch
durch datenmaterial ständig verbessern
und wachsen und zweirad von
stoffwechselprozess durchführt wenn das
der fall wäre
das team will differenziert aus das
bedürfnis hätte er sozusagen ohne die
tendenz hätte sich neue daten konnten zu
schaffen und felder auf die es sich
ausrichtet ohne dass wir das von
vornherein schon einprogrammiert hätten
dann wäre ich bereit es in einem
schwachen sie mehr als lebendig tanzens
waren zu erkennen
scheint ja dass wir gar kein griff im
sinne der definition von leben haben
weil wir ja sonst dass wir ein schreiben
könnten und dann verschaffen können ja
das ist ein guter punkt also in den
beginn des lebens ist sehr schwer zu
definieren werden gibt zum beispiel
thesen ist er kann gar nicht definieren
manche sagen leben ist dazu gehören des
biologischen evolution stoffwechsel
reproduktion selbst geschlossenen system
also es gibt themen theoretische
definition von leben bislang ist ein
poetisches system auto
aber jetzt ist selbst hervorbringen
kreislauf der sich selbst am leben hält
durch dorf wächst punkte vor das ist
doch eine definition definiertes leben
ist natürlich sehr sehr schwierig zu
definieren
ständig werden noch bis 10
also ich wollte nur noch anmerken dass
ich finde man sollte es nicht
überbewerten darauf jetzt am beispiel
des problems auch das externe quasi rein
programmiert wurde oder in köln sich von
sicher ausgestanden ist stellen
sofort das
dann beispielsweise ausländische staaten
oder sondern weg und ich ja im ersten
moment auch das kontingent in chan junis
also das ist auch den besuchern die
küche aus
russland entwickelt haben aber nur noch
bei der weil man sozusagen bei der kg
bei mir das denn sein
faktisch ändert dass wir sozusagen der
creme tube wie man es auch nennen mag so
viele haben das nicht zu sprechen
es ist also ist es schon unterschiede
machen kann sollte aber das hat sich
jetzt für mich okay wieder wie wird sich
das insofern scheine aus beiden
fraktionen und die eingespeist werden
die schöne sprache und formen und also
quasi system kombiniert sind die nicht
so viel interpretationsspielraum lassen
und die preise der wirklichkeit abbilden
wie sie in der mathematischen sprache
darstellbar in die arbeit nicht
zusätzlich seine empfindungen dann
individuelle erfahrungen einfließen
können
dieses schon in dieser weise das auf und
irgendwo wenn die fenster ist wenn ich
als einzelperson aussicht gestellt man
kann es ja auch vorstellen dass
beispielsweise das menschliche genom
irgendwann mal vollständig entschlüsselt
die situation dass man weiß welche
philosophie der mensch allgemeine
arbeiten
welchen traum
und da manha diese 2 system entschieden
[Musik]
er ist an die irischen bonität führen
würde sondern auch diese
zustandsbeschreibung was fragen was ihre
nicht nur die wiederum ausgeht sondern
was seine dynamik sind die bienen
sammeln ist gegenständlich bestimmte
politische gesellschaft
ja das ist das sehen wir kommen da
gleich in die ganzen tiefen konventionen
der genetik oder der naturwissenschaft
rein also wichtig ist jedenfalls dass
wir immer eine gewisse parallele haben
diese analogie zu lebendigen system ein
neuronales letzt behaupte ich jetzt mal
ist diejenige künstliche leistung die
vielleicht am nächsten an solchen
komplexen biologischen prozesse 31
dieses diplom ist hier nicht eines der
wenigen filme was da ganz nah dran das
ist natürlich unterschieden und sie
haben auch zu recht ist die biologische
informationsübertragung sind auch noch
bisschen anders aber es ist so ein
modell was ziemlich komplexes was
ziemlich gut unser gehirn auf den ersten
passat basis mal ein bisschen motiviert
noch zwei meldungen beziehen
die maschine hätte die sich selber
produziert dafür sei hauptsächlich strom
bekommt oder das braucht ständig neue
baut und sich ständig weiterentwickelt
oder an kosten und welche eigenschaften
gespannt was sie während der wendige
system
aber das kommt man sehr leicht machen
einfach alles packen alte simulation was
irgendwie
feldmann
und letzter unsere maschine simuliert
schon sind sie mit sicherheit simuliert
oder sowas softwaremäßig oder
programmierer simulieren aber eben nicht
real als sein als das system was dann
nach außen auf kanal die kann ich
unterschreiben nicht simuliert werden
also ist eine gute frage man das
simulieren kann ich denke schon dass man
zb ein computerspiel
nun kommt er auch da spielen da kommen
auch drauf das ist ein eigenes an
vorsicht da gibt es sicherlich solche
solche kreaturen an verstrichen die
anwender softwaremäßig simuliert werden
wo man ein gewisses nahrungs feld hat
und gewisse parameter hat und dann
dieses dieser entität sich entwickeln
lässt angesichts dieser
rahmenbedingungen aber das ist halt doch
mal was anderes würde ich sagen wir
müssen darüber diskutieren wer mich
jetzt wirklich ein neuronales netzwerk
habe dass ich nicht als leben
die programmier sondern als auch
konzerne
beck sieht selbst diese eigenschaften
entwickelt nur aufgrund seiner
komplexität
aber diese der vorschriften nicht
unterscheiden simuliert werden oder
selber sind ach so ja okay wir als
menschen und für noch nicht
unterscheiden auch wir selber sind oder
nur symbole werden könnte schwieriger zu
sagen das ist keine natürliche und lesen
genauso lebendig positive oder diese
theorie gibt es zum beispiel sagte
einmal ein berühmter philosophen stein
im der dem mann der durch die luft wirft
der dem den würde das nicht stören der
würde das als seine natur einfach
interessanter punkt ich glaube durchaus
dass man noch ein bisschen unterscheiden
muss
von simulation und simulationen und
wirklichkeit anderen begriff ist die
virtualität also virtualität und
realität
das ist eine wichtige position da bin
ich sogar dabei und gast seine grenzen
schlimmen sind aber simulationen würde
ich davon noch mehr unterschreiten
simulation ist angesichts von gewissen
parametern möglich künstlich erzeugt und
der simulation würde ich von realität
und virtualität unterscheiden wir kommen
auf diesen begriffen aufzuspringen
ich glaube da muss man strengen
wahrscheinlichen simulation realität und
virtuelle
wäre ich bereit wäre zwischen
virtualität und realität meer fließende
grenze einzubauen
wir kommen darauf den computerspielen
wenn man sagt dass computerspiele eine
eigene onkologie eine eigene
wirklichkeit erzeugen welche bereit zu
sagen ja das stimmt
und gute spieler haben eine eigene rente
sie haben ja eine realität die
eigenmächtigkeit aber simulation würde
ich nochmal davon unterscheiden aber wir
kommen dann noch mal darauf zu sprechen
sie noch letzte minuten
aber ich glaube dass alles gesagt
zum beispiel das bearbeiten die
informationen wichtig ist dann bräuchte
interessant politischen zeitschriften
gelesen über sogenannte werden
beschreiben wollte sind die ideen
ausgehen
man kommt es zu diversen geschaffen wo
den war dass er etwas diktieren sind
informationen und der die facebook
aufgezogen
das erweiterte etwas cooles gefühl hatte
dass die informationen
dass wieder viele stars und viel musik
und video
nach wissenschaftlichen kann sonst
getreten dass die eu-staaten zu
meditieren und ich sagen dass das
wahrscheinlich infrage kämen sowohl
technische informationen etwas was
griechischen reden von existierenden
parteien die soße genommen werden kann
oder was mit dem situation darüber ist
was mich nur darüber dass ich gut
gearbeitet und meine geistige prozesse
das umformen kam nur zu bekannt dass das
gummi zugezogen steht also nicht in der
welt zur rose und überwiegend in der
post oder punkt information war eine
sitzung unseres seminars ich mag oben
rechts hier wieder bringt rein wo wir
uns ausführlich befasst haben ich habe
damals die these vertreten dass
informationen nur information ist wenn
sie bedeutung
sprich wenn sie ein subjekt interessant
ist und information ist ein bisschen
relativ einmal ist für uns das
informative oder nicht relevant nicht
ich glaube es information ist ganz stark
subjekt abhängig und hat was mit
bedeutung zu inflations und das heute
ein subjekt also es ist eine spannende
frage
wir kommen auf die informationen auch
noch mal näher zu sprechen wenn wir uns
mit virtualität und realität befassen
ich wollte dieses zitat was man hier von
herrn nochmals so eine provokative these
champions netz stellen
er sagt hier der ausdruck neuronale netz
ist dabei ein doppelbett irreführend
erstens besteht ist indes nicht aus
neuronen sind slider strukturen und
zweitens ähneln diese mädchenanteil
zählt ferner immensen kapazität und
plastizität des menschen gehirns das
funktioniert der real mehr in alle netze
das wünschen wir uns noch nicht ganz
noch ganz und sogar fast ist kann auch
nicht die rede davon sein dass die
computertechnik menschliche den
vorgängen bzw
neuronale netze realisierung imitiert ja
glaube schon dass es nicht nur also
nicht ganz wahr die abbildung ist und
dass wir durch diese
von sony mich hier einsetzen durch diese
die platin schichten schon erstaunliche
qualität bieten kann aber es ist
natürlich auch unterstellt ist
ich bin aber ein bisschen optimistischer
hier alles wieder bedienen der hier
recht skeptisch das wollte ihn nur hier
nochmal nennt der johnson charley es
wohl aber mitgebracht also wie er sagt
einfach so viel wie computer erfassen
die bedeutung nicht von ihren kategorien
natürlich immer die frage wie man
bedeutung definiert definiert man
bedeutung als dieses metall muster das
man sagen dieses muster ist nicht dieses
muster und es nicht dieses muster und
diese relation
dieser musste wenn die in dieses muster
selbst in den teilen es nicht das ist
nicht der pflegenden und das ist sein
edition also über die negation des
kontextes ganz minimalistisch die rede
da wirklich sagen kommen mit dem
verstehen ziemlich nahe
wenn wir lernen bieten wenn wir
überleben die kinder zum beispiel an der
prozesse
die bedeutung von gegenständen davon
begriffen betrieb von wörtern gelang
dann häufig so dass das nicht das ist
und dass das in diesem kontext ist seine
dort und so hört man hier auch solche
meter musste selbstreferentiellen muster
zu entwickeln und dann werde man
vielleicht ein bisschen wäre unsere
bedeutung sagte mir die frage ob man
bedeutung zu verstehen
der sat hier das chinesische zimmers
können sie noch nicht genauer durchlesen
simuliert das verständnis des
chinesischen und der sprache mächtig ist
als die frage wann der blick
sprachkompetenz dennoch sorgt er sagt
also in neuronale können sich im netz
überhaupt keine intention ali thet ist
die gericht geteilt es wenn mir das
gesagt hatte auch nicht ich glaube dass
man mit solchen mustern
komplexen musterprozessen ziemlich viel
ziemlich viel erreicht und letzter punkt
war wiederum gehen wir weiter dieses
argument von serviced radikal einfach
nicht zu trennen
es beruht auf einer realistischen
philosophie und einer mechanistischen
interpretation der computer es bricht
wieder verbreiteten gemeinsamen
auffassung bei anhängern der kali und
ihren gegnern
das computer syntaktische maschine
computer sind das was sie materiell
gegenstände die sich mit den mietern der
physik vollständig schreiben und
erklären lassen syntax und das
sprachliche phänomen ist kein teil der
physik die physik beschreiben keine
zeichen keine partikel streben keinen
logischen schluss ja ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher
ich glaube dass diese noten künstlich
wieder einsetzten die tour nach dem
physikalischen modellen
sehr sehr reflexe aber ich glaube hier
gibt es eine chance für die küste
intelligenz so dass wir jetzt ein
bisschen zurück stellen dass es noch
thema der letzte zum lesen jetzt geht es
um das internet und das ist ein ganz
spannendes phänomen und ich glaube
jemand das bild jetzt sei ausgeschlossen
sie sind übrigens alle vorhin auf lukas
punkt net der neueste blogbeitrag
filmempfehlung kath.net definition
genau das ist es also an was erinnert
sich das aber erst dann wenn sie machen
von diesem original genau darum was
könnte man nachdenken ja so ein song
pilz verteidigungssystem und wird es ist
ein guter anlass konnte sie noch immer
so wie viele jahre genau es wird jahre
wurzeln bedingung dass auch im markt ja
genau jetzt aber ganz verschiedenes hat
lippen bild zur stadt bei nacht zum
licht am ich hatte seinen unser
universum also an die studie planeten
also dass die welt das hat es nicht
ändern obwohl natürlich da nicht solche
verbindungen und effizient das ist
richtig und wie sie richtig sagen wir
haben wir zum teil und wird zum teil das
hier ausgefallen ist und ich lese mal
kurz vor was es ist alle teile einer
karte des internets basieren auf daten
von 18.15 bis 2005
das ding ist heute viel größer jede
linie beschreibt zwei knotenpunkten
welche zwei ip adressen repräsentieren
also zwei computer so ist sagen die
verbunden werden die länge der linie
beschreibt die verzögerung zwischen den
knoten problem diese karte beschreibt
weniger als 30
das rc netzwerke wie ich anfang 2005 von
dem datensammeln programm erreicht
werden konnte die linien sind farblich
entsprechend der rfc 1918 adressbereich
gekennzeichnet das ist jetzt anders
jetzt kommt es dass ein dunkelblauer net
cms grün kommen ort wurden mit kaffee
dunkel gpc ntb und so weiter zu führen
also hier sehen sie die verschiedenen
nationalen oder technische bildung die
top level domains entlassen
ich sehe hier sehr viel auch ein
bisschen gelb sehe ich hier sehr viel
gelb ist auch de unter anderem gärtner
und des überaus müssen geld also da
könnte jetzt ihre oder eine homepage die
rettung des ok hatte das ist aus
wikipedia genommen habe ich aus der
bürste quellenangabe das kannst du auch
mal runter hören wollen jetzt nicht ein
paar fakten noch bringen also sondern
studios 2013 sagte dass 77 2 prozent der
bevölkerung ab 14 jahren deutschen
online waren
das entspricht 54 2 millionen menschen
interessant ist auch dieser trend zur
zum mobilen internet
das war 2002 23 und 2013 ein jahr später
fast doppeln zufrieden man müsse schauen
wie es jetzt sechs jahre später ist ich
denke mal
stimmt bei 60 60 70 prozent also wir
sehen offensichtlich dass ein
interessantes aargau das internet auch
dazu neigt mobil zu werden also das
internet ist im vernetzungs system was
nicht geboren ist ein stark ausgebautes
themen sind was die ihre tendenz hat
flexibel zu sein als immer mit zur
klärung dem zentralisierter 2
diese physischen folgen des der mobilen
nutzung scheint in der struktur des
internets angelegtes möchte ich noch ein
statistik zeigen das sind jetzt ist die
anzahl der website die es gibt im web
und wir haben hier eine interessante
sache also es geht richtig los so
eigentlich über zuerst ab 2000 das war
auch darum ich meine ersten homepages
hatte zufall jetzt aber da ging das
einfach erst richtig da war das mit
baukastensystem oder so da war es
einfach handhabbar ich habe bekannte
gehabt die haben schon sich ihre
homepage 4 90 95 gebaut dann musste man
das
noch verschicken mit diskette irgendwie
an dem es zu ahnen hoster verschicken
und der hat es dann drauf gemacht also
dass man das selbst mit ftp server hoch
lädt das ist 1 790 als massenphänomen 7
98 99
neben spears die besten ganz früh wer
also weiter gegen das richtig
exponentiellen könnte man sagen
oder sehen sie jetzt ein paar kleinere
einen blick 2010 lebt seine senkung auf
was führen sie das zurück ich hätte dann
in den zweiten nicht
2010 sehen sie die zeiten wieder runter
genau finanzkrise haben hier musst du
dir war die finanzkrise
von hier sind die folgen dieses glaubt
2010 ergänzen bisschen verzögert könnte
so der folgezeit bisher gibt es in dem
kleinen steinbruch und 2013 in st
15 wir sehen momentan knapp unter einer
milliarde homepages wir haben die
milliarden grenze nicht überschritten
wunderbar ich hätte jetzt gedacht wir
haben das schon wieder ein paar
milliarden wird sein haben wir nicht
aber in extremo internet zu
da fiel ihr das nicht genau das konnte
ja genau da kenne ich mich jetzt nicht
so gut aus ich weiß nicht aber gute
frage und das ist jetzt die aktuelle
statistik zwar von gestern spätabends
risiko gibt es seiten können sie mal
googeln
die aktuellen daten und da laufen die
kam der stelle jungen und als sie wissen
jetzt wirklich knapp unter einer
milliarde website es fehlen uns nur noch
ein paar mit youtube
dann haben wir das nehmen und sie mal
knapp unter eine milliarde ist es also
wirklich gestern haben wir haben hier
3,2 milliarden nutzer und wieviel
bevölkerung hat die welt noch 76
investor milliarden
fast die hälfte also knapp die hälfte
war gestern online e mails wurden
gestern sehen sie 112 dann praktisch
dann also wahnsinnig viel versteckt ist
der wahnsinn
und auch blogs google suchen
auch der wahnsinn alles geht dürften die
milliarden hier rein also das wollte ich
nur ihm zeigen dass ist das ist die
macht des internets die die schiere
daten und des internets so obwohl jetzt
habe ich ein paar weit von lima an sie
und zwar auf folgendes kann worin liegt
die technologische und philosophische
besonderheit des internets wir wollen
nicht nur technologisch zu übernehmen
dass man es als technologische fakten zu
wollen als philosophin und philosophen
uns darüber gedanken machen inwiefern
spielt das internet eine eigene neue
realität
worin bestehen die chance möglichkeiten
des internets und worin bestehen die
philosophischen magnetischen indischen
philosophischer teil probleme dieser
welt sind die fragen die wir uns jetzt
ein bisschen erstellt werden also gibt
es sowas wie ne und theologie des
internet
eigene causa macht doch jetzt möchte ich
einmal so ein paar punkte mehr und sie
können wir gerne dann auch erweitere
weitere dann gebe ich mich jetzt einmal
super grund charakteristika das internet
hier angeben
die auch philosophisch wenn jemand zu
vernetzen das steckt im begriff krieg
verlegen gucken ob es einen unterschied
gibt es nur noch ums überleben auf
unabhängigkeit zeit unabhängigkeit
körper losigkeit künstlich identitäten
schallwellen oder neue realität
so haben sie noch einen anderen und sie
noch andere punkte dazu erstmal ganz
formal betrachtet wie kann man das
internet formal oder und seine
möglichkeiten erkannt
das eigentlich in den winter vertrieben
dass das world wide web zu fans von
anderen
euro von anderen werden
das heute wirklich sei eine neue form
von der arbeit gekommen so etwas ist in
genau als er das internet waren eine
universitätslaufbahn in den usa dann war
es gibt solche militär systeme intranet
also oder punkt des feldbergs gehabt
eine müssen unterscheiden
starbett de was der unterschied wird und
intra mithalten kann lesen sehr
geschlossener kreis ich habe mir könnt
ihr nicht so weit im internet - wohl mal
in servern zu einem flug von demnach
müssen zugang ein ausbruch per 1
im internet hingegen zu genau damit sie
mich die punkt geben das internet ins
telefon offen
das internet ist offen und das internet
kein zimmer weiter
nicht so im netz foren oder sonst
geflecht von pilzen filz wurzeln sich
verzweigen und man kann auch immer
wieder einsteigen und sich einklinken
und das netz und das dauert mit da kommt
man zwar auch das internet
glaube ich hab's nicht gemacht aber ich
glaube so spielt deswegen will ich das
sagen im tendenziell als im internet
bezeichnet
aber da müsste man noch mal genauer
einfach heute vor allem für leichte
ladung mitnehmen
also ich glaube diese unterscheidung ist
ganz wichtig internet und intranet ravel
sind afrikas sind die systeme die
politisch geschlossen großen firmen
genau oder zb atomkraft wäre zb dieser
stuxnet-virus lag der konnte nicht
dieser atommüll anlage per internet
eingespeist werden weil das gaben
angeschlossen waren
das müsste man anders machen dann muss
man physikalisch gegeben also solche
abgekapselt system und das internet und
es kann es wirklich ganz weit fasst
internet ist in strukturen die es offen
die es immer erweiterbar und die sucht
sich ihre weg auch in monsheim und
unsere lebens werden uns im alltag und
das zahlt sich dadurch dass wir jetzt
internet mobiler versuchen zu benutzen
kann
es gibt jetzt diese ganz einfach eine
dreifach schiffs die zähne aus der etat
ist schon finden es diese kleinen chips
die können sich überall einbauen zu
können
jede noch so unbedeutende technische sie
können ein weibchen ihre pflanze
das erdreich der pflanze ein pflanzen
sozusagen dann sendet der insel mit
anderen besuchern der information
darüber wie viel wasser jetzt dass sie
gegossen werden
das heißt sie können sich immer
einloggen auch die tendenz sich immer
neue zu pflanzen und sich einzuloggen
und anzuschließen sie können ganz
verschiedene sensoren koppeln mit diesem
systems also total offen und flexibel
extrem flexible struktur und das finde
ich philosophischen essays sehr
spannenden gegensatz zum internet
das interessante ist wie sie richtig
sagen das internet ist aus dem internet
erwachsen das war mal ein abgekapseltes
system und es wurde immer weiter weiter
immer weiter und das prinzip ist jetzt
einfach offenheit und jetzt kann man
sich natürlich fragen thema grenze wo
liegen die grenzen des netzes und
grenzen jetzt willkommen mehr frauen
sinne des wortes der bedeutung des
wortes grenze aber physikalisch oder
scheren kann das immer weiter wachsen
wie wächst im system gibt es ein limit
wird es allerdings stabil läuft außerdem
ist zu machen
ein weiterer punkt ist die grenzen darf
man alles tun also gibt es regeln in
diesem netz muss es regeln geben und wie
können diese regeln aussehen auch
normative
moralisch gesehen und wieder scheint
dass irene von diesen regeln die uns die
realität definieren und dann kann man
sich sagen schließlich wie hängt dieses
internet sofern die realität sehe mich
warum müssen es als realität patienten
mit unserer realität zwar der zweite
natur kultur deshalb ist es eine form
von kultur spricht zweite natur wieder
meine entscheidung oder gehört es nicht
zu einer treppe natur ich bin der
meinung ist ganz nah dritten natur ich
glaube dass sie ganz eine ganz andere
lobby wird und dass wir nicht wie es
viele machen wollen die regeln werden
200 die unserer moralischen kategorien
eins zu eins an werden können orte sind
das heißt jetzt nicht dass im internet
irgendwie alles erlaubt zeit zurück wir
müssen unseren orten regeln anpassen und
zwar deswegen weil wir es hier um
ortszeit
haben handelt und weil der körper nutzt
und welche identität im internet eine
ganz neue rolle
also ich glaube hier muss erst noch eine
ewige des internets entwickelt werden
das ist noch nicht nicht der fall und
daran wollen wir heute auch noch ein
bisschen arbeiten so jetzt will ich in
diesen netten herrn zeit
es ist leider verstorben sei im moment
drei flossen ein amerikanischer
philosoph aus berkeley kalifornien und
dieses foto hat nicht mal von ihm
gemacht und habe ihr gleich an die
medien gestellt werden wenn sie da mal
schauen sehen sie kommen wir da hab ich
gesagt so und den hammer viert als er
hier an der lmu münchen bauen
meisterkurs gemacht und sehr sehr nette
der 3 wir sind und sehr wirklich
kommunikativ warm und einer der ersten
szene 1929 geboren war einer der ersten
der sich wirklich mit künstlichen genc
befasst hat 172 bordcomputers will kann
die kritik auch harald fischl krise also
eine kritik sehen sie es ein bisschen
bezug zu kant kritik der reinen vernunft
hier gibt es die kritik den künsten
morgen können
bleiben also her dreyfus professor drei
fonds ist sehr skeptisch so wie
eigentlich alle die meisten wie auch wir
wiederum skeptisch und in diesem kontext
ist auch das andere buch was wir heute
wissen wollen ist die zweite auflage
internet 2001 der erste auf leute 2001
gesehen das ist in einer zeit
geschrieben worden wo ist sieht er sich
auch einen blauen balken wo es so ein
bisschen glück gehabt gab es vielleicht
30 mio leitung 100 millionen websites
so müssen wir noch ausgestattet ist
schon 2001 gab es nicht viele 50
wiederum webseite oder nicht viel
deswegen müssen wir schauen dann ist
dieses buch überhaupt noch aktuell
es gibt eine zweite auflage 2000
oder müssen wir nicht doch schauen dass
man hier
dies hat er verändert habe einfach
aufgrund der eigendynamik die vielleicht
damals noch gar nicht erkannt wird kommt
das wesen also was ein bisschen durch
als er ist ein freund ist wie internet
is not just an dem tag an innovation in
diesem aufzug von potash one that brings
out the big 12 15 optional technologie
innovation sap channel partner ist dann
dennis karmann expects alexander graham
bell telephone co ceo for communication
business überhaupt die accepted
interpols hauswände los angeles the wall
street bleibt weiß henry fords ford auf
die und mobile sgm peepli live und in
den büros pesch nur dem
bis freundin des csl limited 16 was wir
jetzt damit haben sie den letzten punkt
verstanden
eben das auto es auch im raum geben
neuen raum für beziehungen zwischen
menschlichen daran hat er gar nicht
gedacht der vor allem dass die site
effekt 12 umstände jeder damit eintreten
die man nicht antizipieren können und
was meint jetzt treffens männer sagt die
internet is not just a new technology
keine schnitte sind antibiotika
innovation der brings out the essence of
technology pascal damit gemeint sein
also keine definitiven das wesen denn
die dezentrale ps mit technologie
überhaupt sichtbar machen könnte was
können
bisher könnten man könnte es auch in ein
rot rotes ein prototyp oder begriff
einen weg suchen müssen ein inbegriff
der technik machen
naja das beweisen wie würdest du die
hier zumindest mal zb getragen sondern
weil ich direkt den tag zu gut
es ist ein guter hinweis als auf einer
anderen ebene gelagert als konkrete
medium und könnte ich immer als mal so
eine starke these man könnte sagen das
internet ins transzendente das heißt im
amerika die bedingung der möglichkeit
von ich glaube es hat also die bedingung
der möglichkeit von entwicklung und
damit das gesagt es ist so eine gewisse
notwendige bedingung also eine
grundstruktur ohne die gar nicht mehr
regt innovation möglich ist ist es nicht
so sehr medium das internet als die
bedingungen der möglichkeit von medium
oder der inbegriff des mediums und ich
glaube da ist was dran
im medio medium heißt er nur vermittlung
ist dass die mit medien medien nicht
wissen der mitte und medium heißt mittel
und das internet ist der inbegriff der
vermittlung also dass die gibt die
vermittlung auch die struktur gebracht
es ist die grundstruktur der vermittlung
überhaupt es geht hier nicht um die
konkrete vermittlung darüber darüber
darüber bilden und so weiter das ist die
basis von informationsvermittlung
schlechthin
camus transzendenten erweitern ein
baustein sozusagen ja also man kann das
da hat sich hier mich noch dran setzen
wenn sie übernehmen bis theologischen
wir haben es hier mit recht nicht
persönlich erkenntnisse erfahrungen und
sexy touristinformationen zugezogen dann
ist wirklich das bild dieses fehlen ohne
die überhaupt keine informationen mehr
erkannt oder vermittelt werden kann
es geht um so eine erkenntnis knochen
ich will das noch mal diesen begriff hat
jetzt wirklich nicht eingreift ist nicht
einfach
ein spiel bringen könnte man sich jetzt
ein bisschen weiter überlegen auch hier
wird nicht nur neue ästhetische
dimension hier im spiel ist die ich
jetzt mal dran zentralen würde der so
weitergeht ist der fall sony in
horitschon mit vorteilen die kirschen
betriebszeit es das haben sie gesagt
dieses internetportal the tales mehr
country reports zu singen
[Musik]
djs of technology ist er mit seinen
exzessen optimiert werden wie internet
ist die wahrheit ist die combination of
the state and may riesling es flexibel
das passiert wird herthas details
interconnect er ist auch realist weekend
but they were produced between unlimited
das kino flexibility national institute
for trading chance als trottel
bekanntgeben ins new way of thinking and
access information im internet bringen
uk wir können das gelebte diversität und
search engine
engines and deliver tourist information
bietet seine software center cajun fotos
in touch mit option wäre die belastung
für virtual worlds mit den aims to have
even more flexible dsz wales in der
world and der bei rwo die menschen auf -
hier wird ist sehr fit angesprochen gibt
eine kleine anekdote als ich damit der
drei stars im raum sprachen wir über
computerspiele und dann fragte ich ihn
der aber computerspiele sind doch auch
eine eigene realität die gehören da auch
zu unserer wirklichen welt gesagt es
gibt mehrere
alles wäre unser weltbild haben habe ich
ihnen können wir überhaupt dass die
grenze zwischen computerspielen und der
wirklichen welt ziehen ist da wirklich
stichhaltige argumente dafür ich glaube
es nämlich nicht weil ich glaube
computerspielen wir kommen darauf können
wir nicht so starke kausale kraft
entfalten dass die nicht von unserer
wirklichen welt unterscheiden sind ich
gebe beispiele das wissen sie alle
kennen sie das konto des spiels dafür
kommt aber auch mehr zu sprechen in
dieser sitzung starcraft ist ein
kennen sie bestimmt erkenntnissen
streichen die spiegel online stellen
gestrichen was zum beispiel in südkorea
zum art volkssport geworden ist wie
fußball dort da sitzen die leute zu
millionen vor den fernsehern oder in
einer wave arena und schauen sowie 2
meist sind es junge männer gibt auch
computer spielerin war überweisen sind
es männer wie die an zwei computern
gegeneinander antreten und dieses
computerspiel gegeneinander spielen und
da muss ich sagen ja würde jetzt solide
oder fußballspiele
würde vielleicht 35 sagen ja ok oder
vorspiel und dann würde ich sagen ja
aber in südkorea
wer ist darf das internet
computerspielen beitrag gehört dass dort
zum fußball und er wird einfach die
grenze fiel vielen verschwimmen hat als
da bist so ein bisschen ebenso ein
bisschen gegenargument gepackt ist
interessant weil das spielen selbst der
real existierend wechselt die räder
trotzdem nicht weil ich habe mich ganz
auf seinem computer spieler existieren
ja klar
[Musik]
die welt der computerspiele wichtig also
ich gebe mein beispiel kommen da ich
werde jetzt nicht zuviel vorwegnehmen
aber in vergeben und kurz beispiel wenn
sie zb eben wörter vor kraft oder diablo
oder so alter muss haben die wirklich in
euro beziffern sind dann sehe ich da so
ein anhaltspunkt dass das wirklich das
es ne das virtualität eine form von
realität wenn dieser zauberstab da oder
dieser mantel mantel von soundso in
diablo 3
wenn der so selten vor in diesem spiel
dass leute dafür bereit sind bitcoins
oder was auch hinter zahlen also
wirkliche wert also anzugeben sind dann
glaube ich haben wir es dann mit
natürlich existiert das was da im
internet ist wie auf dieselbe weise wie
jetzt hier in studios so aber wenn es
vergleichbar wird mit wert zu menschen
mit geld dann scheint mir dann grund zu
lieben als die realität alles gegeben zu
unserer realität gehört wenn es um werte
und kausale kräfte oder wenn sie leute
streiten welcher wert wenn es zu gründen
von einer lebenswelt interaktion werden
kann
dann würde sagen die szenerie diese
kausale kraft und spielt die es verdient
realität gelassen
er bringt jetzt hier im virtual works
und das führungsteam virtualität dann
müssen wir mal genau darauf eingelassen
ist
aber ich würde sagen die virtual tape
und werde die schließen sich so nicht
aus und zwar dann werden sie eben von
bedeutung ist dass alles information
das problem dass er realität ins
gegenteil sind halt eben was in dieser
das klassische problem bisher matrix
angeworben worden ist dass auch unsere
kinder in kleinen schritten
wenn ich mir sehr gut
beweisen das
das ausschalten dieser weltweite machen
kann ich mir seine eigene welt hätte
könnte ich nicht den obligaten schaltet
sich in das chaos um das ganze nicht
ganz so überzeugend im vergleich zu dem
was sind als verdient
das schon richtig aber nehmen wir das
beispiel des computerspiels auch wenn
sie sich auslaufendes läuft das spiel
weiter
ja und das ist auch die gefahr die
dahinter steht das viele leute wirklich
und dieses stichwort second line dass
die dort drin bleiben wollen wenn sie
sich aus logen spiegelt ja selbst
schafft sie sehen das sind spannende
sachen und wir sind hier nur auf den
zentralen ergebnissen kamen ins detail
ein
also was er sagt ist das ist leben wir
mit nummer hier diese diese beispiel
minister stellen die war ist das
perfekte technische geräte wie auch noch
medium und es ist die nomination als
versteck gipfel oder die die im begriff
der tendenz die perfektion der tendenz
alles so flexibel wie möglich zu machen
und alles der realität so weit zu
vernetzen zu für internet zu verbinden
wie es nun
und das scheint direkt grundstruktur zu
sein die nicht nur ein bestimmtes medium
charakterisierten einzelnen medialität
prinzipiell darstellen also das internet
ist ein inbegriff der medialität man
alles ineinander vermittelt wird alles
mit einem beziehungs es und zwar unter
diesen bedingungen werden und raum
losigkeit oder der sportlichkeit und
auch ein bisschen der zeitlosigkeit
jetzt will ich dann noch mal hier jetzt
bringt er hier sein partner effekt alles
sagt diese psychologischen
untersuchungen zeigen dass dieses
internet leben gar nicht so glücklich
macht das ist so eine gewisse
psychologische untersuchungen also dass
praktisch internet und seine
kommunikationsform gar nicht so
attraktiv ist hat also integriertes was
sagt er hier wird die präsent long ist
klar wenn man sich nur von computer
setzt und nicht mehr interagiert
angesetzt angesicht können das problem
habe müsse man zwar besteht natürlich
macht es immer die geschoben das wäre so
ein psychologischer fängt jetzt welche
nach den statistiken zeigen kann
und überhaupt gibt es diese
unterscheidung von ihnen ziemlich gut
gemacht
entspricht es von der bronx oder highway
to riches sagt analoge kultur wird sie
analog und die hyper möglich digitale
digitalität würde dass ich würde es
rechts würden den zweite naturgesetze 2
genannten und hier dann ist erst einmal
der formulierung und das geben wir noch
ganz kurz durch die klassifikation ist
eine tendenz der hypo gerne noten
kulturen sozusagen das alles stabil oder
stange oder je nach organisiert und es
gebe interesse als es geht eher um
kategorisierung was fällt runter wie so
ein karteikasten so müssen dieses punkte
während in hyper text der digitalität da
geht es immer um flexibilität und es
geht nicht so sehr um hierarchisierung
zum alles ist vernetzt sein horizontal
alles ist total vernetzt und müssen auch
alle möglichen assoziationen und das
führt mich zum anderen
unseres denkens ich glaube dass das
denken der ebene der digitalität des
internets als gps technologie dass das
nicht so sehr seine logische
analytisches ding heißt begriffe in eine
hierarchische ordnung zu bringen also
was fällt uns ein begriff oder im
begriff zu analysieren in seine
bestandteile soll ich glaube dass das
ding oder technologie des internets
darin besteht assoziationen herzustellen
spricht einer horizontalen ebene
verschiedene begriffe miteinander zu
vergleichen oder minder dazu verlinken
also assoziatives denken wer es nötig
dass das scheint mir erfolges gibt es
hier den körper und selection des
sorgfältige selektion qualität die
editionen authentizität des textes und
altes material muss ausgeschieden werden
oder aktualisiert werden klar wenn sie
eine alte auflage haben haben sie noch
bücher mit alten auflage die müssen sie
eben mal ausschließen
wie können sie denn hier mit mediation
da draußen vor dem für den bibliotheken
während jetzt das neue internet es gibt
inklusive tät die verfügbar keine texte
und auch die tendenz alles zu
dokumentieren als sind nicht mehr
ausgeschieden
und das ist so ein punkt der dem wir
problematisieren müssen weil ich sagte
das internet vergisst nichts
sie kennen die internetkenntnisse mache
halt und da können sie schnappschüsse
von allen internetseiten auch schon von
solchen mittlerweile gelöscht wurden
wieder herstellen also zum beispiel habe
ich meine homepage
ich weiß wie viele ja mal darstellt eine
nummer noch mal mehr über augen geführt
ja und das ist ein problem weil wenn man
diese spuren die sie im netz bahn in der
10 terrassen die können sie nicht mehr
auswärts das hinterlassen so permanente
studie
und dass dessen hat folgen für das
verständnis unseres gedächtnisses unsere
gedächtnis kultur pflegen können nicht
mehr vergessen und vielleicht auch die
vereinskultur könnte auch verändert
werden also hier das problem ist hier
präsentiert das internet lebt keine
unbedingt mit qualitativen maßstäben
mehr an
das sagt nicht dass es veraltet
unbedingt und das muss jetzt raus
geschmissen werden sind alles wird
aufgebaut es gibt dann vielleicht auch
eine archivierung sie sehen ist dann
hatte software gibt es da diese alten
versionen können gebote lagen
wenn es komplett es probleme gibt aber
bringen sie mir wenn man alles
speicherung vernetzen und es wird nicht
so sehr selektieren haben dass also ein
wichtiger teil sprang und auch noch ein
wichtiger punkt in ihre displays von
server also wer es wird
wie würden sie diese unterscheidung
verstehen ist unterschied zwischen
draußen play von und surft er sich aus
einer fand nämlich sagen dass man im
internet sich so ein bisschen für diese
lässt gern gut und einfach auf reize
schnell einleben kann das heißt oder ist
durch gewalttätig und kann dann mache
ich mir zunächst gedanken was
unterschiedlich und anfang an zu suchen
und genau ich glaube das geht geht in
die richtige richtung
[Musik]
bewiesen wurde ja auch genannt ja
das ist diese raum zeitlosigkeit eine
zeitlosigkeit meint das sind
sekundenbruchteilen ein klick ist dass
die unmittelbarkeit vielleicht auch noch
wichtige weltcup sind nicht übersehen
medialität unwägbarkeit die medien
vermitteln habe diese vermittlung
verschwindet unmittelbar statt und zwar
unmittelbar von den räumlichen
zeitlichen grenzen
dann fühlt man sich gerade darin
beispiel ist ja so salz genau
installieren nicht an grübel ist denn
der bibliothek doch am juni werden wenn
wir irgendwo ein guter text anschauen
wollen
tatsächlich zeigt auf den werden die
jetzt in der bibliothek und findet
irgendwo im keller
wenn ich nicht gerade jemand hat das
keiner mitbekommen ist recht klar
ja das stimmt prinzipien aber was
könnten sie machen wenn sie jetzt durch
an und nehmen sein
[Musik]
meine
auf jeden berg das bücherregal endlich
passte nach immobilien verschwinden ja
ich meine realität ist nicht immer alles
nach was du machst aber wenn du klingst
[Musik]
als ich glaube sie haben beide im
letzten punkt erwischt sie haben beide
erwischen und zwar das ambivalenz in der
analogen welt haben wir die möglichkeit
wirklich umgesehen was prinzipiell
marken gesehen zu sein aber wir können
natürlich richtig heftiger erwischt
werden also physisch aber prinzipiell
ist noch orte der anonymität im internet
wer das prinzip wie eben möglich ist
entwickelt systeme zu überlegen im
internet könnte könnten wir so ein
trojaner drin haben der alles
aufzeichnet also prinzipiell sind wir in
unsere bewegung internet viel besser
erfassbar als dokumentiere als in reale
werte verstecken wir aber im internet
anbieter wiederum stieg von medien und
die möglichkeit weiter meditation zu
schaffen und ist ein vpn client zu kuren
oder sonstige dinge unter dem natürlich
dass sich ausprobieren werden wenn dann
noch ein besserer virus drin ist er
unser formel 1
genau genommen also der google macht da
so viele bestimmt von jedem und anhand
es sag mir was du suchst und ich sage
dir was du bist 2
ich glaube ich nur die zielgruppe
doch wir wussten auch jeder von jedem
was da so
und der rest ist bekannt nur halt in dem
dorf außerhalb geworden hätte spaß von
dem von jetzt an nachbarn freundlich was
du so gut ist
dafür müsste man nämlich google ist
einfach die zielgruppe aber die idee
alles da ist wirklich geändert dass
google nicht besser erkennen lassen
aber wir sollten die frage sein hat mir
interesse ich denke das stimmt es ist
unmöglich dass google das
individualisiert auf kontaktdaten was
ist google wird da wiederum die learning
systeme gibt im netz durchlaufen lassen
und gewisse interessen formulieren zb
für kaufverhalten und so weit vorn das
wären wären aber auch ziemlich nicht
individualisieren vornehmen können also
wieder so ein punkt ist die schiere
datenflut vergibt der besten einzelfall
wirklich jemand herauszupicken
als mann ist durch diese stelle dann
glaubt auch ziemlich genau das
schriftlich zum einen entwickeln sogar
der mächtige werkzeuge und maler
speichern das einfach entwickeln die
nächste werkzeuge oder die daten von
heute in 20 jahren richtig ja das wäre
was stimmt also prinzipiell an sie
richten prinzipiell ist die daten
bewusst dass man den fragen der zeit ist
bis verfahren die pid werden künstlich
immer genannt wird es dann wirklich auch
in die personalisierte medizin
prinzipiell
und alles spricht von großen
geschichtsstudium in der bibliothek bei
den wittelsbachern nur als auch geboten
wenn ein versehen und mussten noch
persönlich mit dem bildungsmarkt ist und
zum beispiel die schüler viel zu sagen
haben stellten geld welches dokument
wieder lesen
und da haben
er ist wichtig und richtig also sie
sehen die grenze sind immer ein bisschen
fließend aber ich finde die haben ja
schon ein paar interessante
unterscheidungen und die wollen wir uns
noch ein bisschen vor augen halten jetzt
müssen wir leider ein bisschen früher
schluss machen
wir werden im nächsten sitzungen noch
mal aufs internet zu sprechen kommen und
zwar von an auf diese philosophische und
jetzt auch mal ein bisschen diese folie
weiter von über 3 fuß der mann auch über
die frage spricht wie während körpers
werden also welche rolle und seien
leider überhaupt noch spielt und
inwiefern das problematisch ist anders
die noch einen schönen tag und fahrstuhl
dem pfingstberg bis nichts